les drones ont changé notre façon de
voir le monde
léger et maniable ils peuvent aller
partout à des vitesses pouvant dépasser
les 100 km heure mais ils commencent à
être nombreux dans le ciel 850 1000 au
canada la plupart pilotés par des
amateurs ou connaissances limitées que
ça va arriver que dans la vraie vie que
vous allez perdre un compas un baromètre
toi un gps et si vous n'avez jamais
piloté c'est là que ça devient dangereux
parce que les gens ont pour les reflex
les usages possibles des drones se
multiplient mais les risques d'accident
sont bien présents on avait cette
situation où tout le monde de natation
drones dans le ciel et puis on a
certainement réalisé que quand quelqu'un
fait seuil toujours la possibilité d'une
collision d'un accident parce que des
gens tous des drones de nouvelle
réglementation tout fait gronde plus de
250 grammes et oblige de réussir un
examen en ligne pour obtenir une
certification
certains professionnels auraient
souhaité qu'on aille plus loin dans la
formation pratique et la certification
du matériel ce qui manque à la
réglementation transports canada c'est
l'expertisé en vol donc d'accumuler des
arts de vol et surtout d'être capable de
voler sans assistance donc passé du
moment ce que les drones seront
certifiés par transports canada ce qui
aurait une vraie certification long pour
faire confiance aux matériels mais
l'historique mal l'expérience nous a
montré que le matériel et flanché assez
fréquemment
donc quelqu'un qui sait pas voler en
mode manuel à des risques en fête pour
la population
certains pourraient être tentés de se
passer la certification ce sera au
service de police de faire appliquer les
nouvelles règles
la police peut venir les voir et leur
demander de de fournir sur place leurs
permis et puis oui si leurs preuves
d'avoir fait l'examen la technologie des
drones progrès rapidement transports
canada suit cette évolution et se dit
prêt à changer nouveau la réglementation
en cas de besoin ici monsieur marsolais
radio canada laval